fire is one of the most important and
powerful of the primitive technologies
it unlocked all sorts of potentials for
us on every level my name is bill
Schindler I'm a professor of archeology
and anthropology at Washington College
and a primitive technologist and
experimental archaeologist fire probably
started as some sort of a natural
phenomenon like a lightning strike a
forest fire would have drawn our
attention we would have seen it and
probably started to realize the benefits
of fire over time we could probably
smell the cooked meat of the animals
that were trapped in that fire and not
only died but were also cooked as a
result of that we certainly would have
seen the light would have experienced
the warmth and the first sort of
harnessing of fire was probably making
sure that that flame didn't go out we
could take that fire and transport it
somewhere else
fire requires just three things oxygen
fuel and heat the oxygen is already
present in the air the fuel can be any
combination of things that will actually
catch flame and hold that energy it can
be wood
it can be dung it can be grasses we
really need to focus on them here is the
heat how is the heat generated and where
does it come from most primitive and
ancestral approaches to fire rely upon
friction to generate that heat the first
thing that you need to do if you're
going to start a fire from scratch is to
make or find a sharp edge if you have a
knife that's a no-brainer
but if you don't if you're in a survival
situation you would have to create that
sharp edge by banging two rocks together
to produce the sharp durable edge and
once you have that sharp edge you can
cut the pieces of wood that you need and
most importantly modify their shape to
suit them to make the fire the two most
common ways of making a primitive fire
are the hand drill and the bow drill
let's start with the most basic form of
starting fire a hand drill then this is
where that the saying you know rubbing
two sticks together comes from but if
you just grabbed two sticks and rub them
together
the only warmth you'd be generating is
your muscles moving for hours on end
you'd never create a fire so in order to
make a hands real fire you need two
pieces you need a hearth board and you
need a spindle that spins inside of the
hearth board both of these pieces need
to be bone dry and made out of the right
materials the hearth board needs to be
made out of something that's not
resinous so it can't be from a conifer
it can't be hemlock or pine or spruce
and it also has to be from a wood that's
somewhat soft my test for finding out
whether or not this wood is the right
type is to actually put my fingernail in
it and see if it leaves a dent behind if
it does it's probably the right material
here in the Eastern woodlands I use wood
from trees like bass wood or tulip
poplar or cedar they're absolutely ideal
the spindle needs to not only be dry but
it needs to be straight and it also
needs to be somewhat soft quick growing
plants like cattail or horse weed or
Mullen or even goldenrod work perfect on
materials like this horse weed that have
all these little knobs these knobs are
going to tear your hands up and they
need to be removed so if you take your
stone tool and hold it perpendicular you
can scrape them off and make it smooth
once you've prepared the outside of the
spindle and cut it to length you have to
pay attention to the very end this end
the larger end is going to sit inside
the hearth board inside the knot you
create and you have to make sure that it
is a very clean cut these little frayed
pieces are gonna disrupt the the dust
pilot you're spending all this time
creating it's gonna disperse it and
you're not gonna be able to start a fire
if it's not take that stone tool hold it
perpendicular and very gently scrape the
edge once you've prepared your spindle
the single most important thing that you
have to remember is not to put it down
on the ground even if you think the
ground is dry it's not and if any
moisture gets to the end of it it's
gonna be a failed attempt at making a
fire so once it's prepared set it aside
somewhere that it's going to stay dry
the next thing you need to do
prepare your hearth board your hearth
board can be split out of the proper
size so I stick I can split the end I
can carve it down but what I'm really
looking for when I'm ready to go is
something that's about a quarter inch or
3/8 of an inch thick it needs to be flat
on the bottom so it can sit there
without Rocking
so if you start with a round stick like
this it can be split on on both sides or
it can be carved down in order to
achieve that those flat surfaces after
you've achieved the flat surface we need
to create a divot in which the spindle
is going to sit and spin without hopping
out the last thing you want to do is
spend all your time and effort and be so
close to making a coal and then the
spindle pops out and the entire thing is
failed and you have to start all over
again so I'm gonna pick up this flake
that I made and I'm gonna use it to
create that divot the nice thing about
these stone flakes is that they have all
different surfaces on them so I can
start the divot with this part and I can
widen it with this part what I'm gonna
do here is not actually do anything to
start the fire I'm gonna actually use
this spindle for a moment like a drill I
want to drill into that hole to ensure
that it's seated and it's not gonna pop
anywhere so very slowly very
deliberately with some downward force I
want to use this spindle like a drill
I've created the divot that I need for
this spindle but you'll notice I'm also
creating the dust and it's accumulating
around the outside of this hole that
dust will never ignite if it's
distributed around the outside of the
hole like that
I need to create a notch where all that
dust will fall in and make one single
solid powerful coal in order to do that
I'm gonna take my stone and carve the
notch and what I'm looking for is just
like this one here it's gonna look like
a slice of pie or a slice of pizza and
the center of that knot should be aiming
for the center of that hole and it
should broaden out on an angle of about
30 degrees or so by the time it reaches
the edge of the wood
your final motion after your creating
that knot should always be downward
because you don't want any of those
little fibers of the wood sticking up
it's going to disrupt your ability to
form that really nice bundle the next
thing that I need to do will determine
the success or failure of of this fire I
need to make sure everything that I need
after a coal is created is at my
disposal in the right place so the first
thing that we need is a tinder bundle
that's gonna take that coal that burning
ember and blow it into a flame I love to
use cedar bark the inner bark of the
cedar tree is perfect for this
application this is what it looks like
when I pull it off the tree and in order
to turn it into a tinder bundle I need
to make sure that I increase the surface
area so that I can allow it to ignite at
a lower temperature and air to come
through so you can take it and move it
like this I'm breaking up and separating
those fibers I need to split the
difference between separating this and
allowing a lot of air to get through and
making sure that there's not a big hole
in which the ember will flow through
something around like this is perfect
and just like with all my other
materials I don't want to set this on
the damp ground once it's done I'm gonna
scoop up anything that's fallen and
stick it right back in okay I'm gonna
start this fire right here in front of
me it has been raining for four days
straight this is actually the worst
conditions in which to try to start a
hand drill fire however you know one of
the things that I do need to worry about
which is not a big of an issue now is
the potential for this fire to spread
but I'm still gonna clear away some of
these leaves you know I want to get
right down to the bare mineral soil the
other thing I need to do before I even
attempt to make my hand drill fire is to
get all of my wood ready so what I want
to do is take this wood and sort the
size of it and I'll start with the
smallest and go to the biggest starting
a hand drill fire in the woods is an
incredibly difficult thing to do it
requires a lot of skill and a lot of
energy if you get to the
you actually get a cold the last thing
you want to do is compromise your
ability to make a fire by not having all
your materials ready it is worth the
effort to spend five minutes doing this
to your wood okay I have my wood ready
the final two pieces that I need now
that I have everything prepared in front
of me is something to catch the Ember
this piece of birch bark works great I
could use a very dry leaf a small piece
of wood and I'm gonna use this to put
right under that notch that I created
and it's gonna collect the dust once
that dust is collected and it turns into
an ember I can take that and pick it up
and very easily transfer it into my
tinder bundle the final thing that I
need is to have a little piece of a
stick ready because that ember that dust
is gonna work almost like glue and it's
gonna want to stick to my hearth board
and I'm gonna use this little stick to
hold that ember in place as I remove the
hearth board so I don't disturb it you
need to make sure that this hearth board
doesn't move one thing we've done to
accomplish that is we flatten the bottom
of the hearth board the second thing
that we could do is hold down the sides
of it if there's somebody else with you
have them hold it if there's not you're
gonna have to hold it with your foot or
you can take a stick like this and kneel
on it the spindle goes in place and you
have to lick your hands especially on a
cold day like this my hands actually
have to grip this spindle and the
spindle has to move and you start nice
and gentle things to look for make sure
that the spindle bottom isn't popping
out of the hole make sure that there's
nothing as interfering with your hands
if you feel like your hands are starting
to get a little bit dry stop right now
and make sure you lick them again I want
to make sure that I'm drying out that
board starting to heat it up starting to
generate the dust and I can do that by
moving very very slowly the other thing
I need to make sure that I'm doing is
using my entire hand every time that I
spin my hands I'm rotating this spindle
and it's generating heat and dust as
soon as I stop it cools down and I go
back the other way
if I use my entire hand fingertip to
palm
getting more rotations before it cools
down the other thing you're notice is if
you're generating downward pressure
which you should be your hands are
slowly gonna move down the shaft when
you get to the bottom you're gonna stop
hold it with one hand continue to exert
downward pressure grab the top of the
other continue to exert downward
pressure and reposition your hands to
the top and continue again this may take
more than one go but I would love to get
it all in one so that would be awesome
so son of a spindle broke let me try
that for you so you don't want this
hearth board to move so the easiest way
to do that is with the side of your foot
all right so it's cold it's damp my
hands are dry though and I'm tired from
trying to do this the best thing that I
can do right now just take a quick break
I'm gonna take off this this shirt this
is much better to show when the hands
are doing the entire
I got it okay we have the coal we have
to use this stick keep the coal intact
and we're gonna let this coal grow the
more this coal grows the stronger it
gets and I'm gonna need all that
strength to transfer this really weak
coal into this tinder bundle my job is
to keep it in one place in one ball it's
possible when I transfer it
I'm blowing very gently to provide the
oxygen I'm holding it on the bottom
because the flames are gonna go up and
we have flame I'll put this on the
ground I do not have a fire yet all I
have is a flame I'm gonna take my
smallest pieces of wood and lay them on
top laying these sticks on top naturally
form a teepee that's the shape it takes
we're starting to get some of the
smaller stuff lit right here the energy
in that system is building it's gone
from tinder to something bigger which
means it's getting stronger and slowly
I'm going to build the size of the
sticks up
then I'm done that's all I need to do a
bow drill is sort of a hand drill on
steroids and a bow drill fire requires
both a hearth board and a spindle but it
also requires a bow which instead of
your hands is used to spin the spindle
the advantage to that is that when
you're using your hands to create to
generate the heat to spin the spindle
you only have the length of your hand to
spin it until it stops for a moment and
goes the other way and that pause for
that split second allows this system to
cool down so if you can extend that
distance that you spin that spindle
without having to stop and reverse the
direction
it's an incredible advantage so if you
take a bow which is essentially a stick
with a with a string on it and wrap it
around that spindle you have the entire
length of that string to go in one
direction without having to stop and
move in the other direction the other
part of the bow drill which provides an
advantage is a handpiece and that
handpiece sits on top of the spindle and
provides the downward pressure so
immediately by adding the bow and the
handhold you're increasing the speed
you're increasing the amount of
rotations before you stop and let it
cool down in reverse direction and
you're increasing the pressure it's a
lot easier to make that fire and a lot
quicker often to make that fire so to
make a bow drill you need to make a bow
this curved piece of wood works great
but you can actually use almost any
piece of wood as long as you attach the
spindle on the right way so it's on the
outside of the string even a straight
piece of wood will work fine but what
you really need to do to make this
successful is make a string that wraps
around the spindle and there's a number
of different ways to do this if you're
in a survival situation and you're
wearing shoes or boots with laces you
can obviously use the laces but other
options include things like
natural plant fibers like this dogbane
here which produces incredible fibers
you can extract these fibers and just
twist those fibers into a really strong
piece of cordage the problem is there's
so much pressure and friction on this
entire system that the natural vegetable
fibers wear
rather quickly my favorite way to make a
bow drill string is actually to use
rawhide or to use leather this is a
piece of brain tanned deerskin and I'm
gonna show you how to quickly make a
string that will not only make this fire
successful but you can use for
successful fires into the future I can
take this razor-sharp flake and use it
to cut this piece of leather in a spiral
pattern and I can make a really long
string out of it I'm gonna fold it over
itself and I'm gonna make a two-ply
cordage out of it which is gonna more
than double its strength it's also gonna
make this string more round which is
gonna make it more successful for me and
it's also gonna make a loop on the end
which will allow me to attach it very
easily to the bow so this is gonna be a
two-ply cordage and in fact this is the
way that all ropes used to be made I
twist in opposite directions just like
this and twist until it kinks on itself
and I'm gonna hold that end all that I'm
doing is I'm taking both of these
twisting them in the same direction and
then twisting them back around one
another in the opposite direction and
it's gonna hold it tight and I'm gonna
go right down the line twist and reverse
twist and reverse here's the completed
piece of cordage and what I'm able to do
is use that loop and send it right
through and I'm gonna stick this right
on the end of my bow I've made a small
little notch here that'll catch it I'm
gonna pull that down to this other notch
give it a little bit of slack so it'll
wrap around the spindle wrap it around a
few times this is my completed bow and
string this is the spindle that I use
for the bow drill fire it's shorter than
the hand drill spindle and it's also
bigger around this end needs to be
pointed this is the end that's up and
fits in the hand piece if this is
pointed there's less surface contact and
there's less energy loss and I can shape
that again with this rock the bottom end
needs to be flat or as flat as possible
the reason I'm making it flat is because
I want that broad flat surface against
the broad flat surface of the hearth
board and there's more surface area
there's more contact there's more
friction and there's more heat the only
other piece of the bow drill set that
you need is the handle this handle needs
to be as frictionless as possible which
means it should be made out of a hard
material it can be made out of a strong
hard
piece of wood like this Osage orange it
can be made out of a shell a hard bone
or even a rock that has a divot in it so
I need to create this divot inside of
this handpiece so it can accept the far
end of the spindle if I'm making this on
a rock I can take another rock and peck
the hole into it if I'm making it on
this piece of wood I can use my flake
and twist it just like this to create
this hole now I'm gonna make that coal
with a bow drill the similarities
between a hand you're on the bow drill
that both have a hearth board and they
both have a spindle but the difference
is that I'm going to exert my pressure
using a handhold on top of the spindle
and I'm gonna rotate that spindle using
a bow instead of just my hands the
advantage here is that that spindle can
travel the entire length of the string
of the bow without stopping and cooling
down as it reverses direction the
advantage of the handhold is that I can
exert a lot more pressure and I can use
a lot shorter spindle positioning here
is really important the first thing I'm
going to do just like with a hand drill
let's put something underneath the
hearth board to catch the Ember the
second thing I'm going to do is position
my body so everything's locked in place
and nothing is moving around and I'm
gonna take my left hand which is a hand
that's holding the top of the spindle
and lock it in around this knee and into
my shin and just like with the hand
drill when I move this bow I also want
to reduce the friction on the string so
you see if I tilt this bow a little bit
it separates those strings and if I do
that that means they're not rubbing
against each other my string is gonna
last a lot longer
so I kilt it down just a little bit but
I'm still moving my right hand parallel
to the ground
start out nice and slow but all of a
sudden you can see this smoke faster
than there was with the hand drill okay
I need to stop now and remove something
because what happened is that it's
slipping out because there's this split
in the wood so I'm going to take two
seconds and I'm gonna make another notch
real quick so that my spindle doesn't
pop out
[Music]
you see there's smoke coming from the
dust pile so I'm gonna take this stick
put it into the back hold the Ember in
place and remove the hearth board this
ember is what I'm gonna use to transfer
to my tinder bundle and then blow that
into a flame and there's my coal
the way you build your fire is largely
influenced by what you're trying to
accomplish if you want light or heat my
go-to fire is a by default teepee fire
if you take a tinder bundle put it on
the ground and slowly begin to lay
increasing sizes of wood on top of it it
naturally forms a teepee if you want a
fire for light you want large flames you
have wood that is organized in such a
way that there's a lot of air between it
and a lot of air between that wood
allows for not only introduction of a
lot of oxygen but there's a lot of
individual pieces of wood that are
acting like individual pieces of wood
and they're all burning up extremely
quickly and that's generating a lot of
heat and a lot of light it's not
generating a lot of coals in most
situations when you want a fire for
cooking you want a good bed of coals I
found the best way to build a fire to
cook with is using the parallel log
method this method is something that I
learned while living with the hodza in
Tanzania what they explained to me this
accomplished was it created a bed of
coals in the quickest way possible so
they would start off the same way they
begin to start the fire they lay sticks
on top of it it would superficially look
like a teepee and talked about going and
then they'd lay all their logs down on
top of one another in a parallel fashion
and they oriented the direction of the
logs with the direction of the wind so
the winds coming up through the middle
you can only do this once you've already
built up enough coals to rearrange the
fire this is an ideal fire lay to build
up the largest bed of coals as quickly
as possible and the reason is because
I've actually closed down that air gap
I'm laying these logs in close enough so
close instead of burning up in huge
flames they actually burn a little bit
more slowly and produce those coals but
I do have just enough of an air gap and
allow the wind to blow through between
these that is staying lit I've built up
this incredible bed of coals in no time
using the parallel fire method in order
cook on this fire I need to spread these
coals out gets a nice hot bed of coals
and in this spot over here I'm gonna put
the meat directly on top of the coals
okay so the meats done
even though you may never find yourself
in a survival situation I firmly believe
that learning and practicing these
primitive skills are an essential part
of connecting with your past your
environment and everything that it means
to be him
you